In that case, stick around,
please come back and it is a
business dinner, back in 2020.
That was attended by Christian
Lopez, and his attorney with
iffy because Ian.
Santos, looking for harbor city
capital, which is a Florida
-based investment firms.
Lopez says, he was pitching him
to invest $300, 000, but Lopez
declined.
The exchange commission is
accused of being a Ponzi
scheme.
Santos denied any knowledge,
but Cynthia because in, and
Andrew Lopez joins us now.
I want to begin with you and,
welcome to the program.
Christian, let me begin with
you here.
Per the reporting, Santos
brought you to a restaurant,
the hidden November of 2020.
He want to do to invest about
$300,000.
Can you tell us what happened
in that instance?
>> Yes.
He was trying to pitch me some
ideas that, basically, is
giving 300, 000, and every tool
in a few weeks, and is not make
any sense to me, honestly.
>> You describe the situation
out of a scene from goodfellas.
Tell me about what you mean?
>> When you go into this
restaurant we, were greeted
very good.
We were like family.
I've never step foot in there
in my life.
I neither had my lawyer, or my
girlfriend.
We go in there is going on to a
second floor, and it's a big
room.
One table, a butler, and George
Santos.
Right there I would say, what?
This is different.
This is nice.
I had never been treated this
nice before, but we are going
to see what's going on here.
They went they ordered some
food, they went to order the
business, and that is looking
at it all along there.
It makes no sense.
>> What were the red flags that
made you suspicious about this
venture?
>> Basically, he was saying,
the worst thing you could say
to anybody.
If you give us 300, 000, you
are not allowed to know what
you are investing into.
Basically, I give money to him,
and I don't know if he is
making bombs, I don't know,
drugs, whatever he invest this
money into, I don't know where
he sending it.
He said, it has nothing to do
with you.
All you need to do is give me
the money, and then every 2 to
3 weeks, I will give you
$3,000.
And I said, how?
How does this make sense?
It just doesn't sound right.
And then he tried to use the
fact that he was in line with
trump, and he had people, and
all of these other things, and
they would do good.
It is things like that.
>> Let's bring you in here,
Tiffany.
You should know that the sec is
looking into this as a Ponzi
scheme, and of course, any
criminal activity suggested as
what's being purchased, what
the money has been going for.
So we will, note of course, we
did reach out to George Santos
for comment, and did not
receive it in this instance.
Tiffany, you know Santos, and
you agreed to dinner is the
liaison in the two, it could be
a scam.
What set off alarm bells to you?
>> Unfortunately, I was the
mediary between Christian and
George.
I read tread data, 1000%, but
thankfully, it did not go
further.
So, essentially, for junior
high school with me we,
attended I.S. 1:25 and sunny
side queens.
After junior high school, we
lost touch, and we reacquainted
ourselves in 2019.
In this case, Christians case
occurred in 2018.
By the time it came to
settlement, it was 2020, and as
a closer to a settlement, I
mean, this was my first, large
case, out of law school, on my
own.
I was excited about it, and I
was telling everybody.
Everywhere that I had worked,
with different annuity
companies, and this is as far
as they go with it.
Harbor city capital, which I
find so ironic he says, fake
news, fake media, disingenuous
reporting.
He never said anything about
harbor city capital, at that
center.
He led us to believe, and lead
Christian to believe that at
the time, they worked for
Goldman Sachs.
The personal banker on behalf
of Goldman Sachs, and all of
these representations is on
behalf of Goldman Sachs.
In fact, so the red flags came
up as far as, you don't know
what you are investing in.
For me, the red flags came up a
media immediately, and when I
read $300,000 a month on an
interest and investment.
I have worked with several
annuity companies, with large
investments.
$3,000 a month is unheard of.
That was a huge red flag, and
there after, he followed up
with Christian sending
confidence, and memorandums,
again, from harbor city
capital.
Acting at the dinner is on
behalf of Goldman Sachs.
It was an employee of Goldman
Sachs, and the fact that
Christian is applying to this
is, essentially, him calling me,
and was very upset.
That was the last conversation
they had at home, which is
where, he said, he was very
upset.
It was an embarrassment to
covax, and was a cpany
current.
I said, listen this is the
nature business, clients have
to choose who to not vote with
you.
And so, essentially, he never
spoke to me after that we'll
have these lines were exposed,
he never worked for Goldman
Sachs, for citigroup, or
anything like that, I was
beyond belief.
Now, you are thinking, somebody
is pulling into their own
pockets to disperse this kind
of money, to create these,
bells and these whistles, to
essentially take advantage.
He was, essentially, going to
make off with, it essentially.
>> At one point, I would say --
sorry to interrupt you, but all
three of us were to shaking our
head, throughout the story, and
just thinking that this is what
you are describing, and what
you are telling here.
Especially, it is not in a
vacuum.
We talk about this as a sitting